flüchtlinge also unbekannten circa
13.000 die obdachlos geworden waren
durch den brand hatten sich jetzt ja an
der straße nach moria neue lager
selbständig anrichte mit bambusstöcken
und planen und jetzt hat aber die
griechische regierung mit hubschraubern
gestern material heran geflogen um ein
neues hemd errichten das jetzt hinter
mir entstanden ist ich stehe jetzt schon
300 zelte und dort sollen nun die
menschen nach und nach reinkommen die
lage im lager ist nämlich angespannt als
ich heute dort markt haben viele viele
menschen zu mir mit ihren papieren an
die sie sich klammern das ist diese
papiere sind ihre letzte hoffnung
irgendwie einen asylantrag bewilligt zu
bekommen und nach europa richtig auf
estland bekommen viele wollen auch nach
deutschland
und die lage ist ja auch bei den
anwohnern angespannt du hast nämlich mit
einigen gesprochen warum sind die denn
so wütend tatsächlich sind viele
anwohner wütend es ist eine insel mit
80.000 einwohnern
wir waren zeitweise 20.000 menschen in
elenden bedingungen und hier an die
einheimischen hier fühlen sich von
europa in stich gelassen
die sagen diese menschen wollen noch gar
nicht sein die wollen nach europa wir
wollen diese menschen auch nicht wir
haben und dass man doch da irgendwas
machen müsste ich war gestern auch bei
einer barrikade dort waren so richtige
wutbürger die waren ziemlich extrem
wir haben versucht lastwagen zu
blockieren von denen sie dachten dass
sie vielleicht material für ein neues
camp bringen würden aber das brachte ja
gar nichts da die neuen materialien mit
hubschraubern herangeflogen wurden ja
und unter mir ist jetzt das neue camp
haben mit einem jungen mann aus dem
lübbe ansprechen können der sehr froh
ist in dieses camp gekommen zu sein
er sagte hier wird der bischof im alten
lager moria habe es oft messerangriffe
gegeben spaß an dass afghanen dort mäßig
raubzüge vorgenommen hätten und menschen
umgebracht hat aber vor jetzt sein
ansonsten sind nicht viele leute noch
nicht viele leute hier denn auch die
geflüchteten und die migranten wollen ja
eigentlich nicht hier bleiben sie wollen
aus russland nach europa mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren